so Michael you said recently in another
interview that you became aware when you
were working on the campaign during 2016
of another potential spy working on
behalf of Intel our law enforcement
agencies controlled by Obama tell us
what you know about that well I've
discussed publicly last couple of days a
an early May approach to me by a former
government contractor in the national
security arena who through an
intermediary tried to get to me and tell
me that the NSA had Hillary Clinton's
emails and that we could get a hold of
them if we wanted them and this this
conversation continued for a couple of
weeks and I eventually told them I had
no interest because I thought they would
be classified material and as a former
Army veteran who held a top-secret
clearance I knew that was fraught with
peril
and you believe that was in effect a
trap designed to lure you in to
compromising the Trump campaign in some
way I said I'll tell you what Tucker for
two years I didn't know what it was I I
gave the information to the House
Intelligence Committee the Senate
Intelligence Committee and the mauler
investigators when I sat with him two
weeks ago or three weeks ago and they
didn't see him at least bit interested I
didn't know what to think of it two
years I scratched my head the
intermediary who's an old friend of mine
we talked about it over dinner dozens of
times we couldn't figure out what it was
and then the news came out about the spy
latching on to the members of the Trump
campaign policy committee and the light
ball turned on over my head and I
realized if this wasn't a dangle of some
sort from it from the you know whatever
FBI and whatever this this was strange
enough where I needed to bring it to the
public I knew the investigators weren't
interested they didn't even take notes
when I told them about it I thought I
should bring it to the public soompi
they're really quick I'm confused by it
so that's pretty close to the heart of
the topic that Muller is purportedly
investigating and consuming all this
money and all of our attention
investigating why would they not be
interested in hearing more
about that right I mean if the US
government had Hillary's emails in early
May when that when this government
contractor was telling us we could get
them then you know why aren't they
interested I got to tell you that's what
really set off the red flag for me
because they just didn't seem the least
bit interested at all they didn't even
take notes I offered them the timeline I
was reading from in my interview and
they didn't they didn't take it that's
just absolutely remarkable
is this we've been following your
personal story for a number of months
now and you got sucked into this I think
and it's turned your life upside down do
you expect to have more contact with
Mahler's investigators well I brought
this to the public just last couple of
days and there's another approach to me
that was done in late May or the last
half of May by somebody who I believe
was organized by the investigators I
can't talk about it on television
because I think you know the Muller team
wanted to talk about it a lot so much
that I think they sounded like the
authors of it I want to talk about that
with the DOJ Office of Inspector General
now that I know that they're responding
to the president positively and they're
looking into these dangles in front of
the the Trump campaign I want to talk
about both of them the one I talked
about in public the former national
security government contractor who came
to me
and through an intermediary in the first
week of May and this other approach that
happened and the last half of May I my
attorney is writing a letter to the
office of internal of the inspector
general asking to be invited to testify
on this well I hope you will be because
unlike Mahler's investigators I am
interested Michael thank you great to
see tell you Tucker you see these FBI
agents that want to go in as well
they're asking for subpoenas so that
they go and talk to the IG about what
they saw sitting in the office at the
FBI there are a lot of great men and
women who are lying agents at the FBI
who want to talk and I want them to know
if they're watching they don't have to
wait for a subpoena because I know those
legal fees are really expensive
the our legal fund that Caputo legal
fund comm will pay their legal fees well
go figure
to the inspector-general because they're
in general and reveal what happened will
pay their legal fees when their work has
been besmirched there are a lot of
decent FBI agents many of them and they
must be the matters most of them most of
them Michael thank you